Sudha Varghese has devoted her life to serving the women and girls...
...from one of India's lowest castes, the Musahar.
She runs a free girls school, offering lessons in everything...
...from math to karate.
Most importantly, she teaches students to believe in themselves...
...and their potential for greatness.
The Musahar women, they are always told that, you are nobody...
...and they internalized that.
And so, they got marginalized into a community that has no education.
So I started the school for girls.
I wanted to give them not just reading, writing,...
...but I wanted to give them skills,...
...karate to protect themselves.
We also have yoga, sports and singing.
There should be an all-around development for these girls.
They should be able to get in touch with the talents they have.
Our girls can become anybody, in any field,...
...an engineer, a teacher, a doctor.
So once, those aspirations are there,...
...I have full faith that their dreams will become realities.
My struggle, my effort is to give them...
...anything that will help them go ahead.